my god grandma's was cruella deville
i think she's flawless she's a
magnificent villain
were you obsessed with the glenn close
one i think she's
obviously the goat but um i also just
love the cartoon
for a really long time well it was the
most fun i think i've ever had in doing
anything in the car going down the road
that was running around and she was
just screaming jasper i enjoyed doing it
tremendously
do you understand well it was
the sweep was something you know you
sweep into the room you do this with
broad gestures
we started a storyboard i had the
feeling that a little of me came through
in the
in the thing about cheekbones got higher
the face got a little skinnier
i don't like to use the word camp but
that was basically it
she never frightened me so i didn't
think i could frighten anybody
else well now what have we here
i keep bumping into people who said my
god i remember you when i was a little
bitty baby and you scared me to death
and i can't believe that you know i
never had that
feeling that it was that terrifying to
me she was
such a fun character and i just i loved
her
i thought she was wonderful frankly i
thought she was just marvelous
i had great respect and still do for the
original
creation i think she's flawless
i had a little bit of trepidation about
it and and um
wanted to hopefully create a character
that would that would
co-exist well with the cartoon original
and that we were just to kind of enhance
it and
and maybe enlarge it a bit i can see
that so he tried
many many different looks and finally
refined it
down to basically a woman who is capable
of being incred
incredibly glamorous because she has a
kind of a mean
shaped lip and her you know there's just
certain subtle things that we worked out
the hair was the last thing we we
figured out
because anthony powell's first idea was
to make it actually quite
chic and smooth and off my face and it
was too
chic so we went back to the movie and
of course she has that wonderful jagged
kind of
spiky almost punk hairdo and so he said
on top of all these outrageous
sophisticated clothes we'll have a very
the punkier the hair the more outrageous
the hair the the better it worked
by the way we're also so excited about
corella deville what's it like to wear
that black and white hair and the makeup
and the clothes it's pretty trippy
it's uh it's wild i mean right now i'm
tired all the time
but uh there are times where i'm like
gonna kind of wake up into it i'm like
this is
bananas were you were you obsessed with
the glenn close one have you talked to
her about it at all
um i really i mean i i think she's
obviously the goat but
um i also just love the cartoon for a
really long time so yes she's incredible
this is but this comes before her story
so this leads to her to where she
becomes true greatness